[Music]
hey there this is sj a writer in heat
culture and today we'll be looking at
what's in my everyday carry
i believe this is something that writers
can relate to and i'll also be giving
some recommendations and some live
reviews about the items that can be
found in my backpack
[Music]
at geek culture all of us have a certain
degree of dna in our blood and for
myself i actually like to show my geek
itself through this
isn't in chub evidently iron man
and commemorate iron man in the movies i
usually have this iron man easily charm
on hand yeah so it's quite the charming
little thing to bring around
transportation in singapore the next
thing in my bag would be the nintendo
switch which are often used to escape
from reality so what a few of my
favorite games would be breath of the
wild mario odyssey yeah i know very
basic but these are the games that i
usually play when i have to go for
events or
when i commute from office to my home or
the vice versa
the vivobook s14 is a 14 inch laptop and
it's compact and lightweight
it weighs about 1.35 kilograms it's
quite slim as well measuring about 16.6
millimeters in thickness so it can fit
nicely in my backpack
but nobody food by its appearance it's
actually quite tough because it's made
out of military-grade material
all these features are great but the
best part of the vivobot s14 is actually
the battery life
typically laptops can run for about six
to eight hours on battery life and asus
actually claims that the vivobo s14 has
24 hours of battery life we took the
riverboat s14 out for spins the other
day so you can get an idea of just how
powerful its battery is hey guys this is
sj and today we're at geek culture's
office where we'll be testing the
battery life of the vivobook we'll be
contacting a battery life test which
will spend over the next three days this
will be just like any ordinary laptop
battery test we'll be doing basic photo
editing listening to music streaming
videos and playing games wait a minute
are you forgetting something
the charger now we're not going to use
the charger for the next three days just
to see how long the battery can last
okay so here we go
[Music]
if you are able to capitalize on some of
the features that the laptop offers you
should be able to use the vivobook s14
for longer hours my favorite phone
actually had the screen shattered when i
dropped it on the floor ever since then
i've learned my lesson so now i'm
learning to use the top sockets so what
it does is that it will allow me to grip
onto it when i take photography edward
events or take notes during press
conferences and the like
as a writer there are days where we have
to attend events back to back it can be
quite hectic and when my phone runs our
battery the portable charger will come
in handy
especially when we have to cover live
events for our instagram stories of our
twitter
the other items i have in my bag would
be like this trusty camera the mobile
phone isn't enough to take photos i'll
have to use it to take photos of the
event
with so many events on the go there's a
need for me to stay hydrated and this is
where the water cleaning comes in handy
it helps to keep hot water hot and cold
water cool
during press conferences or interview
sessions uh i will take downloads
and over here again culture we put the
gig in deep culture and this is why the
nipple is also star wars team
and so that's on top everything that's
in my bag don't forget to like comment
share and subscribe and for more
information on the viewable s1 pro you
can refer to the link below